we all know netflix is massive they were
the og streaming service that destroyed
blockbuster and gave cable tv providers
a run for their money but did you know
that netflix was not only a strong
performing stock but the best performing
stock in the s p 500 for an entire
decade they certainly didn't anticipate
a global international launch you know
all at once in in 2013. those are the
things that drove the stock higher if
you invested money in netflix at the
start of 2010 you would have nearly 100
extra money at the peak for perspective
with amazon you would have roughly 33
extra money and with apple you would
have roughly 25 extra money considering
this stellar performance netflix is
often grouped with the top tech
companies in the world even though it's
only a fraction of the size once the
pandemic hit netflix stock just
skyrocketed even more as people binge
shows and movies on netflix as they
didn't know what else to do
but over the past couple of months
netflix hasn't been doing so hard in
fact netflix is down over 50 within just
the last four months which correlates to
a 150 billion loss in market cap this
makes netflix the fifth worst performer
in the s p 500
so here's how netflix went from being
the number one stock in the s p 500 for
a decade to being part of the bottom one
percent all within a matter of months
one of netflix's most deep-rooted
problems is that they're dependent on
the traditional tv and movie industries
for content in other words netflix's
ability to have a large and diverse
library of content is extremely
dependent on how many licensing deals
they're able to make with production
studios now netflix has been well aware
of this since the very beginning and
that's why one of their biggest focuses
has been producing netflix originals
over the past decade they have pumped
out several phenomenal series like
bojack horseman house of cards and of
course squid game aside from these
originals they've also bought tremendous
shows like money heist and lucifer but
at the end of the day netflix's original
content and strategic purchases only
account for a fraction of their entire
library this means that if production
studios were to boycott netflix for one
reason or another netflix would lose
most of its content and probably a
significant portion of their subscribers
from the very beginning many studios
have refused to license their content in
netflix and with the time the proportion
of studios that refuse to work with
netflix has only increased due to the
rise of competitors by far the biggest
competitor against netflix is of course
disney plus disney didn't even launch
the streaming service till november of
2019 or just over two years ago but
despite the recent entrance into the
market they already have nearly 130
million subscribers
for perspective netflix currently has
221 million subscribers so netflix does
still have about 90 million more
subscribers but if disney was able to
make up half the ground within two years
imagine where they'll be within five or
ten years
it looks to me like it's just a matter
of time until disney plus surpasses
netflix in subscribers and the key
reason for this is that disney is a
full-on production company first they
have walt disney production studios with
all the classics including aladdin alice
in wonderland frozen and the moana then
they have pixar which includes seoul
coco with the incredibles cars finding
nemo inside out toy story and basically
every other animated movie that we grew
up with and then they have a marvel
which includes the entire marvel
cinematic universe from iron man to end
the game the only thing they're missing
is a few spider-man movies and then they
also have the entire star wars universe
and we can't forget about the
mandalorian and then they also have a
large library from national geographic
and then on top of all of that they have
a few oddball movies too like avatar
disney owns the full rights to almost
everything we covered with that being
said disney isn't dependent on licensing
from anyone because they already own
everything in other words disney is a
production company that launched the
streaming service while netflix is a
streaming service that does some
production and as more production
companies launch their own streaming
services like paramount plus it's just
going to become harder and harder for
netflix to retain content and
subscribers
moving on to netflix's second biggest
issue we have the pandemic now this
might be a bit confusing as the pandemic
was originally hailed as a golden ticket
for stay-at-home businesses like netflix
but long term i think the pandemic was
actually negative for netflix for two
reasons with the first being consumer's
openness to try other streaming services
here's the thing most people who are
into streaming shows in the movies
already had a netflix subscription
before the pandemic started what they
didn't have was a disney plus or a
paramount plus or a hulu subscription
and the main reason for this was that
they didn't want to pay for more than
one streaming service on a regular basis
when they were stuck at home though it
made a lot more sense to pick up a few
more subscriptions now to be honest most
of these guys have likely gotten spoiled
with having all these subscriptions and
they won't be cancelling any of them
anytime soon and this includes me as
well but for people who actually have a
social life and to do things other than
just watching youtube and movies it may
not make sense to pay for all these
streaming services and they may cut back
down to just one this brings up the
question of which subscriptions will
they cancel but really this doesn't even
matter because the net gain will always
be in favor of the competition for
example disney plus has gained 100
million subscribers since the start of
the pandemic while netflix has gained 40
million subscribers now let's say 10
million subscribers who have both
subscriptions decide to cut down to just
one even if all of them choose to stay
with netflix disney plus had a net gain
of 90 million subscribers which is over
two times netflix also realistically
this split will likely be closer to 50
50 and might even lean in disney's favor
moving on to the second reason that the
pandemic was bad for netflix in the long
run we have the seriousness of the
competition before the pandemic the
streaming business was simply in
addition to many production companies
businesses but during the pandemic
streaming became one of their top
priorities take disney for example
before the pandemic they were
consistently launching movies that
pulled in over a billion dollars at the
box office and they had theme parks all
around the world but when their revenue
from theatrical releases and theme parks
go to zero overnight where do you think
they're gonna shift their focus the
answer is obvious streaming many big box
films like solo completely skipped the
theaters and launched directly onto
streaming services and it's not just
disney either this scenario is
applicable to all production studios all
of them had much more to gain from the
pandemic and they all started taking
streaming much more seriously so the
pandemic was actually relatively harmful
for netflix
even if the pandemic didn't happen and
netflix didn't have a dependency issue
they still have a massive hurdle across
which is sustained growth here's the
thing netflix has basically put all
their eggs into the basket of video
streaming and this makes sense because
they need to focus on maintaining market
share against production studios but
let's say they do it instead of losing
to disney plus let's say disney and
netflix become a duopoly within the
streaming industry what happens next
well the answer is market saturation
sooner or later everyone who wants a
streaming subscription will already have
an epic subscription you could argue
that netflix has already reached this
point given that they miss subscriber
growth targets and are forecasting weak
growth moving forward themselves but
even if you don't think netflix has
reached market saturation quite yet how
much more could they really grow 300 400
500 million subscribers
even if they're able to grow at a half a
billion subscribers that's only a little
more than a 2x from where they are today
now this isn't a bad thing as companies
mature they obviously can't put up the
same growth numbers but with that being
said these companies should also no
longer be valued as growth companies for
much of netflix's history their pe ratio
has hovered well above 100 and even with
the recent decline they've maintained a
pe ratio over 30. so maybe the recent
decline is just the market adjusting to
the fact that netflix is no longer the
insane growth company that it once used
to be every maturing company faces this
same issue sooner or later some of them
learn to diversify and grow through
alternate streams of revenue while other
companies just stagnate for a while at
the top before they start declining as
more innovative companies take over the
market apple for example faced the same
issue in the mid 2010s iphone sales were
not only stagnating but declining at
first apple tried to combat this by
raising prices on their iphones to
increase profit margins and that's kind
of what netflix is doing right now
but the thing to note is that even apple
realized that there was a limit to how
much they could raise prices and they
would actually lower their launch price
with the iphone 11. so netflix can't
just keep raising prices to substitute
for growth for apple the answer to
slowing growth was focusing on services
like apple music apple care icloud apple
tv and so on and so forth in other words
the key was to offer more value to
existing customers as opposed to trying
to gain new customers netflix is trying
to do this as well with services like
netflix games but the problem with such
endeavors is that they're usually hit or
miss sometimes a new service is exactly
what customers were looking for other
times not so much so the market doesn't
want to give netflix too much credit
until it's proven that they have a
future in something other than just
video streaming which they've nearly
saturated
looking forward it's not like netflix is
going anywhere anytime soon we can't say
that netflix is too big to fail given
that we've seen far larger empires
getting wiped out time and time again
but given netflix's size this is
definitely not something that would
happen overnight if netflix were to fail
it would probably be similar to
something like dish network it would
start with a decade of stagnation
followed by a decade of subscriber
losses to the competition followed by
the decade in which netflix would
actually collapse so netflix has at
least two decades to figure something
out here whether that's expanding their
services into gaming and live streaming
or whether that's becoming a full-on
production studio themselves
given how much time netflix has you
would think that they're safe but then
again you could have said the same thing
about dish 10 or 15 years ago now
personally i think netflix is a much
more innovative company than dish after
all netflix is more of a tech company
than a media company so i'm sure they'll
come up with some creative solutions
especially with reed hastings at the
helm but only time will tell who do you
guys think will win the streaming wars
comment that down below
also drop a like if you're thankful that
netflix pioneered streaming and of
course consider checking out our
international channels to watch our
videos in other languages and consider
subscribing to see more questions
logically answered but until then i'm
hari and i'll see you guys on the next
one